la mondialisation a changé bien des
choses dans nos vies elle nous a donné
accès entre autres à ne full de produits
fabriqués à l'autre bout de la planète
souvent à faible coût mais quand ces
produits voyagent jusqu'à nous parfois
ils ne le font pas seuls c'est ainsi que
certaines espèces exotiques
envahissantes ont pu passer de l'Asie à
l'Amérique du Nord ou elles n'ont pas de
prédateur la grille du frein n'en est un
bon exemple et la liste comprend
désormais un nouvel insecte détecté aux
États-Unis et qui se rapproche
dangereusement nos frontières
les couleurs d'automne dans la région du
Lac Brome annonce le début des vendanges
au vignobles Léon Courville
il y avait pas beaucoup de monde qui
avait des vignobles car les premières
villes ont été plantées ici on a
beaucoup de vent chauds du Sud qui
arrive ici on est protégé des vents du
nord-ouest par la montagne puis on a le
lac Bron qui nous donne beaucoup de
chaleur alors on a beaucoup d'éléments
qui nous permettent de prolonger la
saison
[Musique]
la récolte de 2022 est bonne mais
Anne-Marie Lemire ne dort pas l'esprit
tranquille ces jours-ci
car il n'y a pas que le vent chaud qui
arrive du Sud
un insecte ravageur s'approche de la
frontière canadienne et sa nourriture de
prédilection c'est la sève des vignes
faut savoir qu'ici on est à 10 minutes
en auto des États-Unis ce qu'on sait de
cette insecte là c'est que lui il va
bien hiberner et qui va détruire tous
les plans alors ça c'est la grande
crainte parce que si on perd les plans
c'est des millions de dollars au Québec
il n'y a plus que le refuge dans les
feuilles ce qui fait que la vigne n'est
plus en mesure de produire les sucs qui
donnent la saveur aux fruits
[Musique]
on voyait des
normes sur les poteaux dans les
vignobles c'est là qu'on a su que ça
allait être grave
[Musique]
2022 dans le sud-est de la Pennsylvanie
nous visitons le comté de boxe et le
vignoble de riches
[Musique]
il cultive tes raisins sur 13 hectares
de terrains vallonnés un site qui l'a
choisi parce que les paysages lui
rappellent les contrées de Provence
en 2014 il remarque un nouvel insecte
dans un de ses champs
[Musique]
de plus il y en a très peu ils n'auront
pas d'impact mais ça explosé en 2017 il
devait y avoir 200 à 300 insectes par
plan
ne sachant pas comment contrôler les
festations il ne peut qu'observer
l'insecte vider ses plantes de toutes
leurs sève
tout son champ devient rouge vif tu te
sens impuissant devant ces centaines
d'insectes sur TV
living dans son champ de trois hectares
ne produisent pas de fruits le printemps
suivant tous ces plans meurent
une perte de 250 000 dollars sans
compter la production annuelle de vin
plusieurs vignobles dans le comté de box
subissent le même sort
la région est l'épicentre de la pire
infestation d'un insecte ravageur dans
la production vinicole aux États-Unis
le fulgare tacheté est un insecte aux
couleurs vives qui ressemble à un
papillon mais il fait partie de l'ordre
des pucerons et des cigales
originaires d'Asie il a fait des ravages
dans les vignobles et les vergers en
Chine et en Corée du Sud au début des
années 2000
c'est dans la cargaison de navire qui
serait arrivé en Pennsylvanie en 2014
sur le campus de l'université Pen state
ont rejoint Youri urban biologiste de
l'évolution elle a fait partie d'un
comité national d'experts
de l'insecte aux États-Unis
et les rend plus sensibles au gel
le fulgare tacheté a relativement peu de
prédateurs en Amérique du Nord et ce qui
rend le contrôle de ces populations si
difficiles c'est qu'il réussit à se
déplacer à tous les stades de sa vie
je sais pas quoi
d'habitude un insecte va pondre ses œufs
sur une plante haute et lorsque les
nymphémères elles se nourrissent de la
sève et bien le fulgor n'a pas lu le
manuel parce qu'il pensait eux n'importe
où
il peut se nourrir d'une centaine de
plantes différentes en Amérique du Nord
même s'il ne peut voler très loin le
fulgare acheté réussi en peu temps à
faire son chemin d'un bout à l'autre de
la Pennsylvanie
la carte des comtés affectée révèle
d'ailleurs que l'insecte suit largement
le parcours des autoroutes
il ne se propage pas par ses propres
moyens il se sert des humains pour le
faire
dès le début de l'infestation en 2014 le
département d'agriculture de la
Pennsylvanie déclare l'urgence
il menace ce qu'on a de plus précieux en
Pennsylvanie le vin et les vignes et
c'est sans parler du fait qu'il nous
vole dans la figure couvre nos voitures
de miella et font un gâchis partout
l'État met sur pied un système de permis
destiné aux entreprises qui font
affaires en Pennsylvanie
ce permis atteste que vos employés
peuvent identifier un fulgaire à tous
ces stades de vie et qu'ils connaissent
les mesures pour éviter de l'introduire
ailleurs
il est un cible les événements qui
peuvent devenir des foyers de
propagation de l'insecte
des affiches sur les risques de
propagation du fulgare tacheté accueille
par exemple les centaines de
participants à cette fois agricoles qui
attirent des gens de partout aux
États-Unis dans le stationnement on
observe justement un petit visiteur qui
semble attendre dirait-on le départ des
véhicules
[Musique]
malgré les campagnes de sensibilisation
le fulgare tacheté réussite à s'établir
en quelques années dans 14 États
américains on en trouve un abondance
dans les villes comme Philadelphie et
New York
que le fameux fulgar se taille une place
dans la culture populaire
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'en est-il de la production
vinicole en Pennsylvanie aujourd'hui
pour le savoir on sera chez zackwards
se trouve à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres du comté de burst site de la
première infestation
on ne savait pas trop à quoi s'attendre
est-ce que c'était la fin de notre
production vinicole toutes les cultures
il fallait que ce soit le raisin
c'était personnel
il y en a beaucoup ici
en 2019 peut-être une douzaine Mélanie
suivante ils étaient devenus des
millions partout
mes actes avaient prévu le coup il se
met à épandre nécessite dans les
bosquets des lentes glanduleux près de
son vignoble
l'insecte par son été sur cet arbre
avant de sauter au vignoble à l'automne
certains ont décidé d'éliminer les
arbres mais les fulgars adorent la vigne
alors ils vont venir quand même je
préfère de mon côté garder les élans du
lot qui les attirent puis les éliminer
en traitant les arbres
lorsque l'insecte maigre vers le
vignoble à l'automne Zac et pas un
insecticide de courte durée sur les
vignes en périphérie
l'insecte aujourd'hui avec ses produits
on était au beau milieu d'une tempête et
on avait aucune idée comment s'en sortir
maintenant au moins on sait comment s'en
tirer
certains plans sont tout de même
compromis par l'insecte mais les
dommages sont limités
de dormir mais soyez prêt car ils
arrivent
[Musique]
on rejoint le biologiste Olivier Morin
de l'Agence canadienne d'inspection des
aliments dans un parc à Montréal
[Musique]
le plus tôt qu'on les trouve le plus
d'options qu'on a pour les contrôler
[Musique]
toujours aucun signe du fulgare acheté
mais il n'y a pas de doute l'insecte
arrive à la fin de l'été 2022 il a été
aperçu près de Détroit et dans le nord
de l'État de New York à Bordeaux et en
octobre un fulgare tacheté mort a été
retrouvé au Québec sur une palette de
produits en provenance de la
Pennsylvanie
c'était le troisième spécimen mort à
traverser la frontière
[Musique]
présentement la production de raisin
particulièrement à risque mais également
la production de fruits la secattaque
également les pommiers les poiriers les
pruniers les cerisiers mais l'insecte
pourrait-il survivre à nos hivers
rigoureux on a des modèles qui sont nous
démontrer que le sud du Québec est
propice à l'établissement du fulgar même
si les erreurs sont très froids pour
l'Ontario c'est certain que le climat
concorde avec les ongles sont infestées
aux États-Unis même chose pour la
Colombie Britannique une chose pour
plusieurs secteurs dans les provinces
maritimes aussi qui serait propice au
fugace
[Musique]
le Québec a déjà lancé une campagne de
sensibilisation auprès du public et plus
particulièrement auprès des
propriétaires de vignobles et de vergers
deux mots d'ordre vigilance et
prévoyance
on aussi des équipes qui sont en train
de regarder pour voir qu'est-ce qu'il y
a dans le coffre outils des insectes
qu'est-ce qui peut être demandé pour des
homologations parce qu'actuellement il y
a aucune homologation puisque c'est un
secret pour présent encore au Canada
entre-temps les chercheurs des deux
côtés de la frontière redoublent
d'efforts pour tenter de trouver une
solution à plus long terme freiner le
cycle de reproduction du fulgare tacheté
par exemple en bloquant la transmission
de nutriments de la femelle aux œufs
[Musique]
Anne-Marie Lemire fonte beaucoup
d'espoir dans ses démarches la survie de
son gangin après tout risque fort bien
dans des bandes
est-ce que d'ici à ce qu'il y arrive
vraiment à tombe ici il va avoir des
choses qui vont se développer pour
lutter contre ça on espère
[Musique]